معنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب العربيه في
السودان لنا يعقوب اهلا بك معنا لينا مره
جديده كيف يمكن وصف هذا اليوم من ايام
الصراع على صعيد السودان ككل بين الطرفين
نزاع مساء الخير طاهر اليوم هناك اشتباكات
في مناطق متفرقه كان يوم امس هادئ نسبيا
بعد اعلان الهدنه ولكن اليوم كان هناك
اشتباكات في بحر ام درمان الخرطوم كان
هناك تمشيط وتحليق للطائرات فوق عدد من
المناطق والاحياء السكنيه في مناطق شهدت
اشتباكات باسلحه خفيفه في مناطق اخرى سمع
عدوي انفجارات وكذلك
مدافع طائرات مضادات طائرات كان هناك
اشتباك باسلحه ثقيله في بعض المناطق كان
هناك قصف ايضا شرق النيل كافوري بعض
المناطق في بحري يعني كانت فيها كثير من
الاشتباكات اليوم كذلك في غرب ام درمان
وفي بعض المناطق كذلك في محيط القياده
العامه في فرصه الخرطوم بعض الاحياء في
العاصمه الخرطوم لذلك ممكن ان نقول ان يوم
ان هذا اليوم كان من حيث الاشتباكات
الاعلى والاقوى بعد اعلان هدنه بين
الطرفين طبعا الهدنه لم يلتزم بها سواء
كان الجيش والدعم السريع وكان واضح ذلك من
سماع الاشتباكات والاصوات الرصاص في كثير
من الاحياء كانت لهذه الاشتباكات الان هل
غيرت شيئا في المعادله او انه لا يزال
عنصر عدم الحسم لاي طرف من الطرفين هو سيد
الموقف لا لا يزال عدم الحسم واضح بالنسبه
للمواطن السوداني الامر مختلف للبيانات
التي
تصدفين شيران الى تقدم القوات المسلحه
تقدمت فعلا في مناطق كذلك الدعم السريع
تمدد في بعض الاحياء السكنيه والشوارع لا
يمكن ان نقول ان هناك طرف حسم هذا الصراع
رغم ان كل البيان وكل طرف يعلن انه تقدم
وانه اوشك على حسب هذه المعركه طيب الناس
الان ماذا يفعلون يعني ما الذي باستطاعتهم
ان يفعلوه في خلال ايام النهار مثلا بعيدا
عن ساعات الليل هل هناك ساعات يستطيعون
فيها الخروج لتلبيه احتياجاتهم وهل لا
يزالون قادرين على
الاجلاء من مناطقهم ومنازلهم اذا ارادوا
مثلا اليوم كان هناك قلق امس شاهدت كثير
من مقاطع الفيديو تحدثت مع الكثير من
المواطنين في المناطق المختلفه كانت هناك
حركه وهناك نوع من محاوله استعاده الحياه
التسوق اخذ حاجياتهم كثير من الافراد
حاولوا ان يملاوا الوقود في سياراتهم كان
هناك نوع من الحركه حتى ان بعضهم كان
يحاول العبور من ام درمان الى الخرطوم لكن
اليوم مع هذه الاشتباكات المتفرقه مع
تحليق الطائرات مع القلق الذي انتبا كثير
من السكان في هذه المناطق الثلاث كان هناك
قلق من العوده مره اخرى الى ممارسه الحياه
بالتالي هم حينما
تنخفض هذه الاصوات اصوات الاشتباكات
والرصاص والطائرات ومضادات الطائرات
والاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه يكون هناك نوع
من الارتياح ومحاوله
لممارسه الحياه اما اليوم يبدو ان الوضع
مختلف بحسب كثير مما تحدثنا اليهم وبحسب
طبعا حتى مراسلوا العربيه وكذلك كثير من
الصحفيين المتعاونين ووكالات الانباء التي
اشرت
يعني محلات البقاله محطات البنزين الافران
صيدليات الى ما هنالك يعني تفتح بحسب
الظروف المعركه بالضبط تفتح وتقتل تفتح
وتقتل بالضبط نعم وهناك وعندها حاجياتها
والصيدليات لاننا نعلم ان الامداد الى هذه
المحال او الصيدليات او الاسواق تعتمد
بصوره مباشره على امكانيه الحركه على توفر
الوقود على امان الشارع بالتالي هناك بعض
البقالات الصغيره تحاول ان تلبي حاجيتها
من المخزون الذي لديها اما فكره الامداد
من الشركات خاصه ان هناك كثير من الشركات
التي اعلنت عن نهب لمحتوياتها والسرقه تمت
لشركاتها هذا الامر ايضا يؤثر بصوره واضحه
على امداد هذه الشركات لكثير من المحاكم
التجاريه يعني اقرا الخبر العاجل الان عن
مصادرنا قبل ان يعني اقف على كيف
تستقبلينه كمديره لمكتبنا في السودان ترى
الصراع في الجنينه بدرفور يوقع على وثيقه
لوقف الاعمال العدائيه كيف يمكن ان
تستقبلي معنا مثل هذا الخبر كيف تفهميه
يمكن هذا ان يفسر بانه في الحقيقه خبر جيد
دارفور لا ينقصها اي نوع من الاشتعال لا
ينقصها اي نوع من الحروب في السابق حينما
كانت الدوله مستقره نسبيا كانت ترسل او
يرسل الجيش تعزيزات عسكريه كان هناك تعزيز
امني من ولايات دارفور يذهب الى المنطقه
الملتهبه الان الوضع يختلف لا احد يستطيع
ان يساعد دارفور بارسال اي قوات الى هناك
لان التركيز مصفي الخرطوم حينما تحاول هذه
القبائل مع بعضها البعض ان تحل هذه
الخلافات وان يكون هناك وسطاء من هذه
المدينه بلا شك انه امر يحسب على الاقل
لمن قاموا بهذا العمل ومن شانه ان يسهم في
تقليل حده التوتر الدائر في هذا كيف يمكن
ان نربط بينما يحصل في الخرطوم وما كان
يحصل في الجنينه في دارفور الجيش السوداني
اشار في وقت السابق الى ان الدعم السريع
حاول ان يشعل هذه المنطقه بمحاوله افتعال
بعض المعارك القبليه هناك حتى ينجر للجيش
للتدخل دائما ما اقول ان ما يحدث في
الخرطوم لا علاقه له حتى اللحظه بدرفور
حتى ان حدث في احدى المناطق ما يحدث في
الخرطوم مختلف تماما الجيش السوداني الان
يحارب قوات الدعم السريع يعتبر ان هذه
القوات تمردت عليه في الخرطوم وحاولت دخول
الخرطوم من اطراف الخرطوم للسيطره
والانقلاب على البرهان وعلى الجيش
السوداني هذا امر ربما عززته بعض
المعلومات الوارده كثير من وكالات الانباء
حتى الامريكيه التي تحدثت عن تقارير سابقه
لهذا الامر فبالوضع في الخرطوم هو الصراع
حتى اللحظه بين الجيش والدعم السريع حاولت
كثير من الجهات استغلاله بما فيها حتى
النظام السابق ولاحظنا ان كثير من الاصوات
التي بدات تعلو الان ولكن اصل هذه المشكله
هو هي مشكله عسكريه تتمثل في تقدم الدعم
السريع في مواقع الجيش السوداني ثم بعد
ذلك هذا الرفض وحدث هذا الصراع العسكري
بعد حدوث هذا الصراع اتوقع ان تكون هنا
يكون هناك صراعات في دارفور نتوقع ان يظهر
كثير من رموز النظام السابق نتوقع ان
تشتعل بعض المناطق كثير من الجهات التي
تحاول استغلال هذا السبب لتحقيق عندما
شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات
والشروحات لنا اليعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه
في السودان شكرا لوجودك معنا مره جديده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات